news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
let me ask you a question what do you
think is the real coronavirus
death toll it appears it could be more
than
54 000 deaths higher
than the official death toll and i'm
going to explain how the cdc data points
us to that conclusion in a second
but at least to start theoretically
anytime you have something
as big as a pandemic which infects more
than 5 million people in the united
states we're at 5.2 million official
cases
it's a country of more than 330 million
people people die
every day for coronavirus and other
reasons there are co-morbidities there
are other
factors it's going to be unlikely that
the official death toll
is exactly what the real death toll is
for the virus
now on the one side there are conspiracy
theories from the right that are about
deception and politics where they say
the real death toll is much lower
it's not 166 thousand it's much smaller
they claim this is not me this is the
argument some on the right make
a lot of deaths are being counted as
coronavirus and they're really not
and they'll talk about someone died in a
car crash and
a hospital counted it as coronavirus
because they get more money that way or
whatever or democrats are lying and
blowing up the death rate
in order to make political uh points or
whatever the case may be now you should
be
skeptical of that theory and indeed
there's no
evidence for that theory other than if
you want to be anecdotal
there might be cases where it's not a
car accident but
you know it's an infection caused by a
comorbidity and an elderly person
who had coronavirus and maybe there's
like some debate as to should this or
shouldn't this count
as a coronavirus death but these are
small numbers of situations
in a country with 5.2 million infections
you're bound to have some anecdotes like
that but
on the other side there's a much more
compelling reason to think the real
coronavirus death toll
is dramatically higher than the official
and it is something called
excess deaths the number of extra deaths
during the march to july period suggests
that more than 54 000 additional people
have died of coronavirus be above and
beyond the
uh official death toll this is derived
when you look at
excess deaths and in the united states
because we have so many people and so
many years of data
and such detailed statistics about
disease
we know how many people on average will
die
of all causes based on our population
based on what's called the normal amount
of death
we know okay if you add up expected car
accident deaths cancer deaths heart
disease flu altogether
we know when you don't have a pandemic
how many people typically die
and if you look at the deaths we would
expect from march 15th
to july 25th you see that during those
dates there were almost 201 000
excess deaths deaths beyond what we
would normally have
and during that time the official
coronavirus death toll
was only 147 000. that leaves about
54 000 extra deaths not officially
attributed
to coronavirus now epidemiologists
favor looking at excess deaths
to gauge the impact of a pandemic
because excess deaths don't depend on
testing people and knowing exactly who
had the virus
posthumous testing testing when someone
goes into the hospital
etc and indeed when you look at excess
deaths everything tracks consistently
with this theory if you look at where
the excess deaths disproportionately are
it's in the state's hardest hit by
coronavirus and it is a very coherent
story that excess death analysis points
us to so in all likelihood
the real coronavirus death toll right
now
is at least 54 000 deaths higher than
the original one
it's even more because that was march 15
to july 25.
in the two weeks since july 25 we've had
a resurgence in deaths
and in all likelihood there are more
uncounted deaths during that period
so what is the likely real coronavirus
death toll remember official is 166.
it's probably somewhere around 225 to
235
and rapidly approaching 250 000 deaths
we are going to have to accept that the
death toll
is much higher than many think when the
pandemic is so widespread
when tests are still today taking five
to seven days or longer to come back
with results
we know we aren't capturing all the
cases and therefore
it follows we're not capturing all the
deaths either
we later will have to see what is the
long-term
impact on the lungs on the heart
on other systems from having and
recovering from coronavirus because you
could have a situation
where years down the line there are
premature deaths
caused by damage done to vital organs
by coronavirus we don't know the extent
of that yet that's something
the medical community is looking at any
deaths are tragic
we have many unnecessary deaths due to
the failed
trump response but we also just have to
face the reality that by now
we probably have somewhere between 55
and 60 000 deaths
that are not in the official death count
which are
due to coronavirus which gets us to
what happens in november and how
is the right trying to get themselves
reelected
despite donald trump's failed response
let's talk about that next